We big-time 50,000 views, huh
Terron Forte the eighth-grader, love your motor young fella
Odds of getting into the NBA
Talent and hard work aren't enough
You also need someone in the corner who knows a system and how to play it for you
Coach Gaines, Liberty prep
We're offering your son a full ride scholarship, and that's how much we believe in his potential
Promise me you're gonna work just as hard off the court as you will on it? I promise
Sup my name's T. So ya'll got a daycare team you ain't told us about? Yo coach, am I starting tonight?
Yeah you're gonna be starting little man
Minute after never
You don't need to go to class all the time
You have practices, workouts, games
I want you to bury your nose in this playbook. Good
Come on Forte,  you're in
Show us what you got
You see that pass? He's only fourteen years old
You are now an official prospect in the eyes of the NCAA, and I alone handle the recruiting process
These coaches, these agents they are gonna use you so we have got to figure out how to use them to get out
What the hell do you think you're doing meeting with him? You realize how involved you are?
How much did you hear?
I heard everything
We don't play for coaches, we don't play for college, we don't play for the NBA, we play for the brands
Whole things rigged against the people it should be helping the most
He's the reason this all exists, and he can't be paid one dollar
You just got to keep putting in work alright?
What if you don't make it?
Stay away from my player, Rob
If your son is the player I believe he is, he's gonna be making millions of dollars while he's still a teenager
You